all right one other thing to get to this
is a from the Sun it says Britney
Spears's father last night defended the
controversial legal order that sparked
worldwide outrage insisting she could
have died without it speaking
exclusively for the first time about the
13-year conservatorship which controlled
almost every aspect of the troubled us
pop star's life Jamie Spears claims he
is far from the monster he has been
painted as in his first interview in
more than a decade Jamie speaking ahead
of a book by Britney's ex-husband Kevin
Federline about fatherhood in the midst
of public drama said quote my God where
would she be without that
conservatorship now I ain't I ain't
gonna paint you no pretty pictures
that conservatorship was one hell of a
time and without it I don't know if she
would be alive now
Jamie 70 years old has endured slurs
that claimed he wanted power over
Brittany 41 to line his own pockets and
micromanage her career even though he
says all decisions under the order were
taken jointly with a quote group of very
good people her fans saw him as a
controlling Puppet Master you know this
whole this whole story is frustrating to
me
because he had this Pitchfork mob uh
that has assembled demanding that
Britney be released from her
conservatorship despite having
absolutely no idea what was going on
behind the scenes okay no idea and I
made this point at the time it's like
you're calling free Brittany you don't
you have no clue what's actually
happening you don't know you saw a
Netflix documentary
it's all you saw
that wasn't even pretending to be
objective
all they knew is that is what Britney
Spears told them and surprised Britney
Spears doesn't think she should be under
a conservatorship because every person
who is in a conservatorship
doesn't want to be in one that's that's
why that's
just assumed
that doesn't mean that automatically
like any time you're forcing someone to
do something of course you have to force
them which means they probably don't
want to do it but the fact that they
don't want to do it doesn't necessarily
mean that it's wrong
it could I mean it could be wrong but it
depends
like there there are people in the world
who are a danger to themselves and
others
okay whether Britney Spears is one of
those people
that's a different conversation but
those people exist there are those
people out there
and uh for people like that
these kinds of Arrangements can be
necessary because otherwise they're
going to hurt themselves or hurt other
people
now as for Britney Spears what do we
know about her uh well we know a lot but
based on what we knew she was a nut case
she lost custody of her own kids in
California
a woman lost custody of her own kids in
California do you know how utterly
disastrous of a mother you have to be to
lose custody of your kids
in California no less
so we knew that we saw all the crazy
stuff on social media uh we saw how she
Rambles incoherently like even when she
was defending herself and trying to
explain why the conservatorship was
terrible she couldn't string together a
coherent sentence
she's like incoherent
does all of that mean and now she's like
posting 56 nude pictures every day it's
just like it's it's like naked babbling
incoherently it's all the signs of a
crazy person
does all that mean that she actually is
crazy well I can't say that for sure
because I don't see what's going on
behind the scenes but but like it seems
like all the signs are pointing in that
direction and there are no signs
pointing to her being actually sane
does that make her dad a good guy no
because he pimped his own daughter out
to the music industry when she was like
15 years old
so he at a minimum consented at a
minimum to having his teenage daughter
turned into a you know into what she was
turned into
so um
you know her first song she was like 15
16 when she'd perform that song
so he's obviously not a good guy
which is why if people had been arguing
that someone else should have control
over the conservatorship then that would
be one thing but instead they said free
Brittany
and just Freer entirely
and now she's probably gonna be dead of
a drug overdose within a couple of years
and all of her fans that called for this
like this is going to be partly on them
this is this is what you wanted
like she does anyone think she's going
to live to 50. does anyone think that
does anyone see that happening
seems very unlikely and that'll do it
for this portion of the show is move
over to the members block hope to see
you there if not talk to you tomorrow
God
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]